And now for the homework. It comes in two parts.
In the first part, you get a mystery-test function
that is the function which returns pass or fail,
for which you don't have the source code,
and you get 5 string inputs all representing HTML input.
Your job is to determine 5 simplified inputs
in which every character is relevant and which make the mystery-test function fail.
So, from a hundred-line input,
this is supposed to return the 1 line or the 8 characters or whatever it is
that suffice to make the mystery-test function fail.
Hint: There is Delta Debugging for it.
The second part is actually just the same as above.
However, try to produce these simplified inputs with a minimum of tests.
For this you can rely on the HTML structure, as we just saw.
Your challenge, of course, is to split these inputs
into tokens, attributes, and regular text in the first place.
Second, not only should your approach take a minimum of tests
for these 5 inputs but also for other arbitrary inputs.
And also, possibly, for other arbitrary mystery-test functions.
We might even make a competition of that.
Who is able to come up with the best simplifier for HTML?
The winner will get La Grande Coupe de Débogage Delta,
which is how Delta Debugging is called in French. Enjoy.